Okay, let's get started
with our first session today, Advances Next
Generation Radioligand Therapy, and we're already arguing up here, is it
radioligand therapy or is it radiopharmaceutical therapy? Anyway.
I'm Julie Sutcliffe, I'm from the University of California, Davis.
I'm also the co-chair of the AACR Cancer Molecular
Imaging and Theranostic Task Force.
So our field to date is clearly
dominated by two targets, the somatostatin
receptors with the approval of Lutathera for the treatment of neuroendocrine
tumors, and PSMA with the approval of
Pluvicto for the treatment of prostate cancer.
So the questions for this session are, well,
building on the advances and the success of these
radioligand therapies, what's next?
What's the next target? What's the next indication?
What's the next radioisotope? I think you probably all got a lot
of questions.
So for this session, we have three speakers, myself,
Dr. Jason Lewis from MSKCC, and Dr.
Reschke from Novartis. And we're going to talk about
our own experiences from both the academic and the industry
perspective of taking radiotherapeutics from bench to
bedside. We're going to have three talks back-to-back, so no
questions, so hold your questions because we're going to keep most of the meeting
for a 30-minute panel discussion at the end.
We find that there's going to be a lot of questions, so
if you can hold your questions till the end.
And if we don't answer those questions in the next 90 minutes,
the AACR is hosting a special conference in January next year,
Cancer Biology Informed Radioligand Therapy.
So if you can pencil in those dates on your calendar, it's here,
January 7th to 10.
So I'm going to kick off,
I think I'm going to kick off,
by sharing some of my lab's personal experiences in taking a
compound from bench to bedside.
These are my disclosures relevant to today and what I'm going to talk to you about,
as well as my faculty appointment at UC Davis.
I'm also the founder and CEO of Luminance Biosciences.
So I do hold intellectual property that's been licensed to the company on
some of the molecules that I will talk to you about today.
So the target that we've been interested in for
over a decade now, sorry, should I say two decades now, is
the integrin alpha V beta 6. You may have heard a
little bit about it. It's an epithelial-specific cell surface
receptor.
It's undetectable on most healthy adult tissue, but
it's highly upregulated in many cancers, including some of the most
lethal malignancies such as pancreatic cancer.
It plays a key role in invasion and metastasis, and unfortunately, its
presence on tumors is a negative prognostic indicator for the
patient. So we and others, we're not the only people working on this
target, believe that the high contrast between malignant and
healthy tissue and the functional relevance of beta 6 makes a
good target for the development of both diagnostics and
therapeutics, i.e. radioligand therapies.
So our efforts started, and we spent a lot of
time in the diagnostic space. So when
we started to look at the integrin alpha V beta 6,
nothing was known about the target. There wasn't a crystal structure.
So we went to the literature, and what we were finding was a lot of
publications with regards to the role of alpha V beta
6 in the foot-and-mouth disease virus.
Well, the foot-and-mouth disease virus is a virus that cattle get.
So you're probably wondering, well, what's that got to do with developing a
cancer diagnostic or a therapeutic?
Well, it turned out that the virus got into
its host cell via the integrin alpha V beta 6,
and the crystal structure of the virus was known.
It turned out that a 20 amino acid peptide on the
GH loop of viral protein one was responsible for
shuffling the virus into its host cell.
So long story short, and 10 years of work, we took
that 20 amino acid peptide. So you'll see
A20FMDV2, so from the foot-and-mouth disease virus.
It's called two because it had a lysine mutated out of it.
And we spent a decade tweaking it. At that point, I have
a lab full of chemists, so all they wanted to do was tweak with the structure to
improve its stability, come up with cool ways to radiolabel it
with fluorine for PET, because we did a lot of F-18 PET work
then. Before we came up with this agent that we're now
calling F-18 alpha V beta 6 binding
peptide. So I just highlight the amount of effort that went into just
developing the first F-18 radiolabeled peptide
for diagnostic with PET. A lot of preclinical testing, a lot of in vitro
testing, in vivo testing in many different mouse models.
Multiple iterations on this compound to get it stable, to get it
targeted. So after that 10 years of work,
we applied for our first IND with the FDA, and
we opened a clinical trial in patients with breast, colon,
lung, and pancreas cancer. So what you're seeing here, and
hopefully it's pointing, yeah. On the left here,
is a patient with metastatic lung cancer.
This is a maximum intensity projection image through the
patient one hour after the injection with our F-18 peptide.
And you can see here uptake in the lung, but also in
these bone lesions. Now, this is clear through the kidneys, so these
dark spots here are kidneys. We do see a little bit of activity in the
stomach and the GI tract, but this is an F-18
image taken one hour after injection of the
peptideHere you see another patient,
metastatic breast cancer. So you see the primary.
We're seeing lymph nodes. We're also seeing bone metastasis.
This patient has a lot more GI activity than this patient.
We're seeing quite a bit of variability from patient to patient.
Now, one
image that was shocking to us was when we took this agent
into non-small cell lung cancer with patients with brain mets,
and we saw here what you're seeing is a slice through the brain.
This is uptake of our compound in the brain.
And what you're also seeing is healthy brain doesn't have any
compound. So we're seeing this exquisite resolution here.
That lesion in the brain was three millimeters, and for those of you in the
PET world, that's below the resolution of the scanner.
But taking into account the super high affinity of our agent with the
clearance in the background, we were seeing these super tiny lesions.
So I pause here, and you look at the timeline.
The first peptide we developed was probably in about 2004.
We are now at 2017,
and we are still only seeing. And of course, we're
seeing a lot more, but we're just detecting at this point.
And so what you're looking at here,
the image on the-- This is a patient that came to clinic with a
suspect recurrence of breast cancer
following bilateral mastectomy, following multiple rounds of
chemotherapy and suspect recurrence in the lymph node.
That's what she thought walking into the clinic.
Insurance declined her FDG-PET, so she entered into our
clinical trial, and this is what we saw one hour after
injection of our F-18 peptide. So yes, there's
uptake in that lesion, as expected, but we
saw all this bone uptake. Now, my first
reaction as a chemist was, did the fluoride fall off the molecule?
But remember, this molecule had been into 20 patients prior.
It's very stable. So we looked towards the CT scan of this
patient, and these lesions were real. These were bone mets.
So went back to the referring oncologist,
who called the insurance, and they got the FDG-PET.
Turn my phone off here. Got the FDG-PET.
And you're seeing is this is the same patient a week apart.
No treatment in between. The FDG-PET actually didn't
show all of those lesions, though it showed some of them.
So the message here, though, this was really a tipping point for my lab
because yes, FDG-PET saw five
lesions. We saw several hundred.
But the patient already knew they had metastatic breast cancer.
This didn't help them. We saw more, but so what?
So for us it was a tipping point is what can we do with this
information to actually help a patient?
How can we make this into a therapeutic?
Well, what we're all here for today is radioligand therapy.
We can do this using a radiotheranostic approach.
So we went back to the bench because, as most of you know,
fluorine-18 does not have its therapeutic radionuclide counterpart,
and we had to re-engineer the molecule.
I'll be honest, we re-engineered it also from an intellectual property standpoint
because we're now going into a therapeutic. IP is very important.
So we re-engineered the peptide.
We're calling it five-G.
We put a DOTA chelator on there, so you could radiolabel with
gallium-68 for PET imaging. We also put
an albumin binding moiety on there for the therapeutic, so we could increase the
blood circulation time for, and then again, same DOTA chelator
for chelating lutetium.
But we went back to the bench where I told you, what have we done?
We spent 10 years developing the diagnostic.
We went back to the bench, and we had to do all the same in vitro assays, all
the preclinical work. And I want to highlight here,
this group, the Lustgarten Foundation and Stand Up to Cancer,
and some of you are here today from those foundations.
We could not have done this without their support.
In 2018, they put out a grand challenge to
take a compound from bench to bedside in one year,
and they gave us a million dollars to do that.
So that's exactly what we did. We did all this work in one
year. We ended up with two compounds, the gallium agent
for the diagnostic, the lutetium agent for the therapeutic.
Both of them with nanomolar affinity for the target alpha E beta
six. Both of them have high serum stability, so properties that are
very important when you're developing radioligand therapies.
Both of them bound selectively to alpha E beta six and were
rapidly internalized. So this becomes important now as we're delivering
this therapeutic payload. Our molecule is internalized.
Both molecules had good tumor uptake and
tumor retention. And the lutetium preclinically showed
good therapeutic efficacy.
So in October 2020, so yes, all this was done during COVID as
well. I should highlight that. We filed our second
IND to the FDA. And this time for the
theranostic pair. So just for your
information, this was a single IND application that covered both molecules.
And I've already told you, these are very, very different molecules.
So we got our IND approved, went through within, I think it was
29 days. We were very, very happy with that.
And then we moved on to opening our clinical trial.
Again, with support from the Lustgarten Foundation and Stand Up to Cancer,
who funded the clinical trial.
So this is a first-in-human study,
evaluating the safety and efficacy of the gallium and
lutetium
pair in patients with locally advanced or metastatic
pancreatic cancer.Now, the goals of the trial,
number one, can the gallium detect lesions in patients with
advanced disease?
Are the molecules safe? Are they well-tolerated?
And what's going to be the maximum dose of our lutetium agent?
So these were our goals,
and here's our study protocol. Standard eligibility,
patients must have progressed on previous lines of chemo.
Obviously, this is not first line today.
Washout from chemo, two weeks.
The lab parameters that obviously, as you're aware, we're
keeping an eye on is, as you saw, our
agent goes out through the kidneys, so we think the kidneys are going to be our
dose-limiting organ, so we're monitoring creatinine and eGFR
throughout the study.
So patients who meet eligibility come in for a gallium scan.
They have a five milli-- and again, this is all first in human with these agents,
so there's a lot of safety monitoring going on throughout.
They come in, they have a five millicurie injection of the gallium, and we
image them, so we're getting some pharmacokinetic information on this if we wanted
to use it as a standalone diagnostic, and we image them one hour, two hours
post-injection, a lot of lab work on the way, EKGs and vitals
monitored throughout.
And then from the image analysis,
we're looking at an SUV of two times normal.
So if they have lung mets, it's two times normal background in the lung.
If they have liver mets, two times normal activity in the liver.
If they have that, they're then eligible for the treatment.
So they've come down to this part where they're enrolled into the therapy arm.
We designed this protocol around Lutetium.
We didn't want any surprises from the FDA, so it's a 3+3 dose
escalation study. We started with 25 millicuries with a
goal to get to the 200 millicurie based on what's currently in the
clinic.
Whether we need it or not, we give the amino acids.
We didn't use amino acids in our preclinical work, but we were
working towards protecting the kidneys.
And we do give anti-nausea medication.
So patients come in, and this is a single dose.
I highlight that because as I'm showing you the results, it's just a single
one-time dose. Patients come in, they get the dose.
Again, a lot of safety monitoring here,
but we bring them back day one and day seven for SPECT imaging
so we can get the dosimetry on each patient.
We added this. Obviously, this is really, it's a phase one, it's all about
safety.
But as we progressed up to our top dose, the question was, are we seeing any
efficacy as well? So we modified the protocol, and we've added
in a follow-up gallium scan,
approximately 30 days post-treatment.
Now, we know that's early, but we don't want to keep patients off any other
treatment options. So we now have this 30-day
gallium PET, and we monitor patients for up to 90 days
with just labs, again, looking at changes in creatinine and changes in
GFR.
So this is
images from one of our earlier patients.
This is a patient with advanced pancreatic cancer to
liver,
had progressed on Folfirinox, gemcitabine,
came to trial with mets to liver.
So what you're looking at here is a MIP image, one hour
post-injection of the gallium agent.
As expected, like the F 18 compound, we're seeing
excretion through the kidneys. We see a lot of uptake in
these liver lesions,
but we also see lung, also see bone.
Now, these lesions were not present per standard of care
prior to our enrollment, so we're seeing additional lesions in this patient.
This patient obviously was eligible. There's two times normal.
These SUV values were 17 times.
So this patient was clearly eligible for treatment, had the single
injection, and this is just the SPECT one day post-injection.
So you're seeing the same thing excreted through the kidneys.
A lot of people have asked us about GI.
Well, with the F18 and the gallium agent, the short half-life, it's
hard to tell. But here with the lutetium, what we're now able to see, it's
actually not binding. It's clearing the GI.
So you're seeing clearance, and you're seeing clearance through the kidneys.
And what I'm just showing you here is a transaxial slice through the
liver. The top is the gallium, the bottom is the corresponding lutetium.
They're not identical agents, but the lutetium is actually on the
same sites as was predicted by the gallium.
And we were fortunate to be awarded the
SNMMI Image of the Year in 2023.
So that's one of our earlier patients.
This is--
and I'm constantly now being asked, "Are you seeing any efficacy?" This is a
patient, and I should rewind and say at top dose.
So we fully dose escalated to the 200 millicuries, and this is
a patient, a lady with mets to liver,
heavily treated. Folfirinox, then went for surgery,
back on Folfirinox, external beam, gemcitabine.
When she entered the study, not only did she have a lot of disease, it was
rapidly progressing. Her CA19-9 was skyrocketing.
So she got the single injection of--
well, she was eligible. There's the uptake in the dominant lesion, the left hepatic
lobe.
Eligible for treatment, got a 200 millicurie dose.
No SAEs, no adverse events. Brought her back 30 days
later. So this is the transaxial slice through her
dominant lesion before treatment and after treatment.
And you can almost, if you squint, you're thinking, "Okay, maybe it's getting a
hole in the middle," but the SUV value dropped by
40%.No change in size. This is
non-contrast CT.
So no change, but it didn't grow. The message here is it didn't get
bigger and she was rapidly progressing when she entered the study.
Her tumors were growing by the week when we were measured on CT.
And also we monitored her
right through the 90 days.
I wanted to give another dose on that, but this is another story.
And her CA19-9 also dropped. So like the PSA, are we getting a
readout from the CA19-9? So her SUV value dropped,
the CT size didn't change
and her CA19-9 also dropped. Again, only a single dose.
I highlight this patient because this actually
changed patient treatment management.
Again, a patient who came to study,
mets to liver,
treated, again, heavily, heavily treated, multiple lines of different
chemotherapies with mets to liver.
But when we scanned the patient, yes, we saw mets to liver.
We also saw bone metastasis. We
also saw-- Sorry, lung metastasis, bone
metastasis, and as we're doing eyes to thighs,
we also picked up something in the brain.
So this is a very small lesion in the brain.
SUV, I think was about three or four in that brain
lesion. To which I call up the referring
oncologist and said, "Yes, this patient's going to be eligible
for treatment, but now we're seeing these other lesions that we
didn't expect." To which they said, "Julie, patients with pancreatic
cancer do not get brain metastasis." I said, "Well, our
agent doesn't go to healthy brain." So the patient then went the
next day for MRI.
So it was confirmed that this was a brain metastasis.
So unfortunately, the patient wasn't eligible-- Well, was taken off our trial, so
didn't receive our treatment. Went on to palliative
radiation to the brain lesion and to the bone mets.
So this is where we see that we can have an intervention in patient
management. I'll start to speed up.
So summarizing the pancreatic data, we've
imaged a lot of patients now. We've probably imaged about 40 patients.
We fully dose escalated. Ten patients actually received top
dose. When I say seven here completed, because three of them opted not to
come back for the follow-up scan, so we can't include them in the data set.
But again, nobody had any adverse events.
We are imaging
mets in the liver, mets in the lung, mets in the brain.
We actually have imaged three patients with brain mets now.
So patients with pancreatic cancer do get brain metastasis, and we
are seeing it, and hopefully in the future, we are going to be able to
treat that.
SUVs dropped in a couple of patients. SUV stays steady in most.
Two patients clearly progressed out of the seven.
Four of them either showed a decrease in CT size or stable.
I'm just highlighting this. This is a single
dose, and that's how we designed our protocol for the start.
It was first in human, but it's a single dose.
I'm hoping, and I'll tell you a little bit more about that, that might change
shortly.
So building on that, we opened another trial in patients with non-small
cell lung cancer with mets to brain, building on our imaging data
there. And this is just one patient.
We have imaged, I believe, seven patients to date so far, treated
three.
You're seeing uptake in these spine lesions.
Again, this little ditzel here was not shown on the standard of
care imaging. We were seeing more.
The interesting-- And again, this is just transaxial through the lung.
Interesting with this patient,
treated brain metastasis. So really, I know where
the brain met was. So if you look here,
you might see a little faint, but it's a treated brain
metastasis.
What I didn't know when we brought the patient in to scan them,
they'd done a treatment the day before.
So I was worried about we're going to see this big flare.
Nope. There was no inflammation. So it was very just an
interesting result, and for the patient,
clearly negative now and moved on.
And then we opened another trial, a basket trial,
all metastatic cancers. And this really is new because this is a patient that we
scanned last week.
This is a patient with high-grade ovarian carcinoma,
high expression of beta six in this patient population.
We thought that, but we had to prove it.
So this is our first patient with ovarian that we've scanned, and you can
see here this patient is really, really, really heavily
treated.
We are seeing she's got lung, liver, abdomen masses.
We are detecting them all, this big mass in her abdomen.
I'm hoping that when I get back to California on Thursday,
that we'll be treating this patient
with our lutetium.
So with that, the reality of this it takes a
lot of people, it takes a lot of resources,
it takes a lot of funding.
When we started this development, I was a basic science lab
in Davis. My students were chemists and
engineers. Ten years through the development, we transitioned
over to the School of Medicine, so we're now in Sacramento.
And my team profile looks a little bit different now.
We have chemists, we have engineers, but we have nuclear medicine technologists, we
have the surgeons, we have the clinicians, we have the nurses.
And the most added value to our team are the patients.
We couldn't do this without them. We do this for them.
This is our practical reality is. It's my lab here,
my small group. Our scanners are here.
We're making the drug in my lab.We're running it over to the
clinic. Patients are getting their scans.
We're treating them over in another infusion center.
Yes, we are cleaning up toilets and setting up bathrooms
for the lutetium.
Patients are then going across into the hospital, getting inspect.
And these patients are amazing. None of them fall off study
because of this.
And we make it work.
So with that, I'm going to
stop. I hope you're convinced now that the new target beta six is a
good target
for imaging and therapy. We have two imaging
agents and a therapeutic agent.
No treatment related SAEs, favorable dosimetry.
We're next.
Multi-dose, hopefully.
I requested the FDA before I left a
meeting, provided them a new protocol for
multi-dose in this patient population.
I think some of you are probably aware there are some changes in
guidelines floating around about dosimetry, especially in
patients like pancreatic cancer, where renal
toxicity is really not their priority or their concern.
We're looking at combination therapy.
We've just got a paper under review right now combining our agent with a PARP
inhibitor, olaparib. And as you saw already, our
molecule is not a theranostic pair really.
It's gallium, it's lutetium, it's two different molecules.
So we're looking at other isotopes where we can actually pair.
So the 64 and 67. So with that, I'm going to move
on, and I'm going to hand over to our next speaker, Jason
Lewis.
Again, we'll do all the questions at the end.
Thank you, Julie. So, Julie gave me the
task of coming up with new questions and new opportunities in
theranostics.
Or as I would say, radiopharmaceutical therapy.
We'll never get this controversy over, will we?
So here are my disclosures.
There we go. Just have an inability to say no to anything.
The reason why theranostics I think is so exciting and so important is, of
course, the heterogeneity that we're dealing with when it comes to cancer.
We all know this. This is why we're having this meeting.
And the ability for a theranostic to both diagnose or
visualize this level of heterogeneity, because we can look at different lesions
within the patient rather than relying on multiple biopsies, is the fact that
these treatments can also overcome and treat this heterogeneity.
With the path lengths of the radiation that we're giving internally, we should, at
least with an alpha and a beta and OGE emitter, have the ability to
treat a heterogeneous tumor when we aren't reliant on
a homogeneous expression at the target.
So that's where theranostics comes from.
I'm going to focus mainly on antibodies in this. Julie does peptides.
I do antibodies or small molecules or peptides.
Whatever works is what we will do.
Everything has a plus, everything has a minus, everything has advantages, some have
disadvantages, but I'm going to talk about antibodies for this.
And the theranostic pairing that Julie talked about earlier, in our case we use
zirconium as opposed to gallium for an antibody.
Zirconium, just like fluorine-18, gallium-68, is a positron
emitter, but it has a half-life of 72 hours.
So that half-life of 72 hours allows us to see the longer PK
that's associated with an antibody. We can't do an antibody with fluorine-18.
The radioactivity is decayed before we see what's happening with the antibody.
So we actually also matched the radioactive half-life with the actual
physical
distribution of the platform that we're carrying around.
So zirconium antibodies, there's companies, Telix and so on and so forth, who are
now bringing these into later phase trials.
They have the ability to visualize cancers, metastatic
pancreatic cancer there at the liver when we're imaging the presence of CA-99.
As Julie mentioned, seeing brain metastasis is important.
We actually do see brain mets with radiolabeled antibodies because the blood-brain
barrier has been disrupted, allowing penetrance.
And we also have the opportunity to look at examples like this in a multiple
myeloma where we can take...
Arrow's not working. Where we can take the actual drug like
daratumumab, the CD38 targeting antibody.
We can just label that directly, put that into patients, and when you look at the
FDG of that patient, you can see you can't really see much of the myeloma, but when
we label the actual drug the patient is getting, in this case daratumumab,
we can see the full extent of the myeloma present in this patient.
So working with the very lovely Charlie Rudin, I'm not sure he's here.
I'm not going to go into biology, but I thought that giving the DLL3 story would
be the best way to talk about some of the opportunities we have.
And the opportunity is that in radiopharmaceutical therapy, we can
hit targets of low abundance.
Generally, when most people look for treatment for cancer, they're looking at
something that's expressed as much as possible in the cancer.
In the radiopharmaceutical world, that's not necessary.
DLL3 is not hugely expressed, but the background is
zero. So if we're thinking about an imaging agent, it's about contrast.
We want as much in the tumor with as little in the background as possible.
DLL3 offers that
10 times. And the nice thing about also the radiopharmaceutical world is
we're not adding milligrams of antibody per kilogram.
We're adding milligrams total body.
So we also at the tracer level have the ability to image and
delineate targets of low abundance without the point of saturation.
I'll show you some examples from that now.
So the opportunity here was taking a failed ADC trial.
This failed. This was the Rova-T trial using SE16, the
Semstentrix. Charlie led this trial. Great waterfall plot.
They had good responses, but it was stopped because of toxicity.
Not because of the antibody, but because the ADC, which was designed to be toxic,
was so toxic, but also to the neurosystem of the
patient. So it was stopped because the toxicity associated with the
ADC was too much. But it didn't mean the antibody wasn't any
good.So getting rid of the ADC and getting from
Stent Centrics, just the naked antibody, the SC16, this was
converted into a radiopharmaceutical.
Sai Sham was a postdoc who did a lot of this, but just to get back that theranostic
aspect again, we've now got the naked SC16, no ADC,
so no toxicity expected, and we're labeling with zirconium for imaging and then
lutetium for therapy.
So this is the first
user patients we're doing is the small cell lung cancer.
And as I said earlier, we can inject small amounts of
radiopharmaceuticals. This image is actually with injection of just three
milligrams of radiolabeled antibody, not per kilogram, but three milligrams
total. The other important thing is with antibodies, we often have
this antigen sink that's in the liver.
But if you're talking about small cell lung cancer and you're doing prostate
cancer, we want to see the liver. We don't want opaque livers.
And so we can actually titrate antibody, allowing us to see this.
And in this case, this is a 70-year-old man with stage four small cell lung
cancer, and these are the liver metastasis from his small cell lung
cancer in his liver.
So we're annotating it. I don't normally do this, but we've got the cover of Lance
Oncology, and I tell everybody this, if you get a Christmas gift from me, it will
be wrapped in paper made from that cover.
The other exquisite thing about this, we can turn this into a theranostic.
So we can now put lutetium on. And the graduate student of mine and Charlie's
did this, Katie Tully. And the small cell lung cancer, as you can see, when we
turn this into a theranostic, in mice, we completely obliterated and melted
away every tumor because the advantage we have, and this is the opportunity with
small cell lung cancer, is they are generally very radiosensitive.
So when you have something that's very radiosensitive, like small cell lung cancer,
delivering radiation directly into it, you're going to get profound responses, and
that was certainly shown in mice.
More recently, the phenomenal work that really came out from many others, like
Misha Beltran over in Boston,
showed that neuroendocrine prostate cancer, which is on the rise because
people, when they start failing PSMA, they come back, and eventually they may have
neuroendocrine prostate cancer, so it's a large growing population.
It's an incredibly deadly and aggressive variant of prostate cancer.
Once a gentleman is diagnosed with neuroendocrine prostate cancer,
there are no treatments. There's resistant hormone therapy, and the patient is
likely to succumb to their disease within one year.
There's no FDA-approved imaging agents or treatment agents for small cell lung
cancer. What Misha showed in their rapid autopsy program
was outstanding, was the fact that at the diagnosis, there is no
DLL3 in the primary disease, but in the metastasis, it is
overexpressed again at the metastatic stage in the
neuroendocrine prostate cancer lineage.
Now, it doesn't mean that a tumor is either one or the other.
She's also now shown that there's a transdifferentiation, that these tumors
transform, or lesions can transform from one to the other, and so you have a mixed
population. Again, why we have to image, because biopsy is not going to cut
it. But because we already have a protocol open, we can do the animal
studies,
with Yu Chen's wonderful organoids and PDXs
of neuroendocrine prostate cancer and show that PSMA negative, but it is
DLL3 positive. And we can also take this into patients.
This is a prime example of
what Julie was talking about earlier.
This is a patient who has neuroendocrine prostate cancer.
On the left, their DLL3 image, and you see the two lesions being lit up.
On the right, their FDG. And some people will say, "Well, hang on a minute.
It's only picked out two lesions out of all those lesions." Well, what's it
done out of those 74 lesions on the right-hand side?
It's picked out the two which are the neuroendocrine prostate.
The rest are adenocarcinoma, but it's now telling you these two, and these two are
not going to respond to any treatment this patient's currently getting.
These two are the ones who will continue to grow, and ultimately, the patient will
succumb to their disease.
Because we can't be biopsying every
lesion on the right-hand side, but now we can actually tell the interventional
radiologist, "Go in and biopsy these two." And for example, these two were shown to
be neuroendocrine prostate cancer.
Of course, with PSMA and the market that's available for that, we also want to make
sure that how does this look compared with PSMA.
On the left-hand side, there's an example here showing that neuroendocrine prostate
cancer in this patient, a lot more lesions light up, which aren't PSMA negative.
Sometimes they can be positive, negative, sometimes negative, positive, sometimes
they can be both.
On the right-hand side, neuroendocrine prostate cancer, unlike adenocarcinoma
that goes to the bones and other places, also goes to the liver.
And so on the right-hand side, you can see the amount of extensive
neuroendocrine prostate cancer that's deposited in this patient's liver.
And on the bottom here is the team that run all the clinical trials for this.
But again, it's really giving you a handle, the opportunity to truly visualize what
is going on in the biology of this patient. It's not about one lesion.
It's about trying to get a handle on all the lesions.
As I mentioned, there's no treatments for this right now, and this is a very deadly
and various and, um, deadly variant.
But the one thing, the opportunity is here is that neuroendocrine prostate cancer
is very radiosensitive. So it's absolutely right for the use of
theranostics. And so another graduate student then took
this incredibly
deadly variant of prostate cancer, treated it, and completely also
destroyed the tumors because they're very radiosensitive.
The other opportunity, of course, is if you go back here, now you've identified
those two lesions, maybe you can irradiate those two, even with external beam.
You can't do the whole body, but maybe now if you find that one or two lesion you
know is not going to respond to anything, the radiation oncologist might be able to
irradiate just those as well because they will respond to, hopefully, external
beam just as they much do an internal emitter.
The opportunity came that more cancer biologists started doing really
clever stuff, and the other thing that just recently popped up was the fact that
in gastroenteropancreatic neuroendocrine neoplasms,
which takes me a long time to practice how to say
showed that in well-differentiated neuroendocrine tumors,
there is DLL3 expression, but in particularly in the poorly differentiated
neuroendocrine carcinomas, the DLL3 expression is
increased.And so this again, because you had the trial open, the
biology there is now saying this is a valid thing to do in these patients.
We should also image these.
We had the ability to take the samples from patients, grow PDXs.
Candace Parker and a couple of our oncologists were involved in this,
where Candace is a postdoc in the lab.
We can take those samples from patients. We can have PDXs.
We can then stain them. Is DLL3 present? Yes.
Can we image the mice? Yes, we can. So what does this look like when we go to a
patient?
I love showing this because I have no idea really what it means.
There are two patients here, pancreatic neuroendocrine carcinoma
and pancreatic neuroendocrine tumor grade three.
On the left-hand side, this is our DLL3 PET again.
On the right-hand, on the second image over, is their NetSpot
image. This is a FDA-approved NetSpot image.
As you can see, they're kind of picking out the different tumors.
But if you look closely, they're picking out different parts of the
tumor. I don't know if there's penetrance into the antibody, but if you look on
this left-hand side here, you can see that there is
like a ring of the uptake of the tumor for the DLL3.
But when you look at the neuroendocrine imaging agent, it's on the
inside of that tumor. So we're actually within lesions picking out different parts
of the biology here. On the right-hand side, the
dotatate didn't even pick out the lesion.
It wasn't even somatostatin, well, it may have been somatostatin positive, it
wasn't visualized. It wasn't until we looked at the DLL3 PET that it
also identified that this patient had a pancreatic neoplasm that was DLL3
positive.
The other important thing is when we talk about these theranostics, it's not just
pairing that imaging agent with the radiotherapeutic
radiopharmaceutical. The imaging agent has importance because it's going to tell
you about the biology of that tumor regardless if you treat them with a
radiopharmaceutical or a CAR T-cell therapy or an ADC or a small
molecule. You're identifying the presence of a target.
What you treat with that doesn't have to be the radiopharmaceutical.
It can be anything. And this patient, I think, was really interesting because
this is a gallbladder tumor that they had gotten
chemotherapy, but they'd been treated with a DLL3-targeted
T-cell engager. And we could first of all say that there's the target present.
They can go in and get the T-cells. But even when the patient was under this T-cell
therapy for DLL3, we could still go in and image
the patient. And the opportunity again here is that even,
for example, when we have patients on ongoing Herceptin therapy, getting three
mgs per kilogram three times a week, we can still go in with radio-labeled
Herceptin and visualize the target because we can kind of sneak in stealthily
to see if there's still target expression. It can tell you a number of things.
Is target still there? Have you given enough drug to actually hit all the target?
If you haven't, then you've got the opportunity perhaps to give more if you haven't
reached toxicity. So you can really start handling and using these diagnostics as
a better way to hopefully come up with better treatment paradigms and, dare I say,
personalize the treatment for the patient.
More recently,
another indication popped up. DLL3, so
neuroblastoma. This is just being submitted this week.
DLL3, the wonderful work coming out of Andrew Kung and
the De La Cruz labs, along with
fellows, have now shown that in the neuroblastoma world, that DLL3 is being
overexpressed. The other opportunity, I keep saying the work, that was the
task Julie gave me, is also the fact that pediatrics is
an area that we absolutely, I think, put in radiopharmaceuticals.
Think about the success with Y-MAPs, GD2, so on and so forth.
The pediatrics, when done properly, could be an absolutely right
population for the deployment in radiopharmaceuticals in a very
thoughtful way. And this was the case certainly with neuroblastoma.
So working with Anne Cochran, who might be in the audience.
Oh, there she waves. Hi. Who's actually a pediatric oncologist who's come
to the lab as a fellow for a few years, along with
Candace and Sal, did some imaging of these
neuroblastoma models in mice, demonstrated
again that it's stained for DLL3 positivity.
And Andrew and Phil's labs have got some awesome biology
that's to go on with this. I don't really understand, but it's very awesome.
Nope. That changed my...
And also showed in animals it lit up.
So let's go and see what this looked like in a patient.
This is one example. I think they've done six patients now.
So this is
delineating, again, DLL3 in a patient with
neuroblastoma. This patient is a 22-year-old male.
They came to us. We see about a third of the neuroblastoma patients in the country.
Came to us, I think, as a young child.
Has failed external beam, has failed every chemo, and can tell you
everything else that this patient has failed because the poor boy,
well, man now, has failed all these treatments.
But of course, the one thing that you do is image with MIBG.
We can't even get high specific activity MIBG now, so that's an issue in the
States. But when we interrogate the patient for expression of
DLL3, you can see very clearly, first of all, the
superiority of the PET image compared with SPECT, but also the true
extent of the disease that this poor young man has throughout
his body. Needless to say, the following day when this image came up, the phone
call from, she called Mo Dakin and we outside, "Can we now treat this patient with
lutetium?" That's hopefully going to start towards the end of the year.
And if you have any more questions about the neuroblastoma, Anne will be happy to
answer them at the end of the
talk.
So this has been using the opportunity, deployment of this
SC16 antibody throughout the entire time.
The company aren't actually going to pursue that antibody any further.
So we actually have now gone through,
I guess, an identification process where we now have our own
DLL3 antibodies. They're human antibodies.
We used that special mouse that make human antibodies, and we got about 200
hits, and now we've isolated down just one antibody,
010, to really confuse everybody when they look at the patent.
But, again, this now we actually think is even superior to
the SC16 in terms of not just the imaging qualities you see here, but
also at least in the therapeutic data that we get.So
going forward, what are the other opportunities?
Julie spoke about this earlier, and I
want to expand on it now, is the fact that all these radiopharmaceuticals at this
point are being dealt with just as single standalone agents.
There are trials now coming out when they're being combined.
If you're going to go in and break apart some DNA using an internal emitter,
then perhaps a PARP inhibitor should be deployed in order to stop the repair of
that inhibitor. We do know that you can give a small amount of a
radiopharmaceutical, and you can elicit an immune response in a
immunologically cold tumor that can then make the immunologically cold
tumor immunologically hot, and therefore responsive to PDL-1
and PD-1 treatments.
And I don't think we've even begun to scratch the surface on how we can
thoughtfully and carefully combine these radiopharmaceuticals
with some of the agents already out there.
The other area of opportunity is, as for many of you know, that we have alpha
emitters, we have beta emitters, we have AU emitter.
But not all tumors are made the same.
So something that might be very good for dealing with really big disease like
yttrium-90, may not be very good for micrometastatic disease
whatsoever. So combining these isotopes
together in a thoughtful way, and this is one trial which I think is a really
cool one that's happening right now, I'm really excited to see how it
happens. Combining the alpha with the beta and hopefully
getting a differential, or an improved treatment response because of the
completely different size and all the tumor volumes that may exist in the patient,
I think is an exciting way forward.
And it does seem right now, at least in this readout, that the cocktail approach is
superior. And it might allow you to dose down, for example, the actinium
side, which might have more side effects and increase the
beta side,
in order to get a better response, whilst the combination should hopefully lower
activities.
Radiopharmaceuticals are awesome, been doing this 30 years, but they
aren't without challenges. And so when I talk about opportunities, there are also
things we have to deal with. This was a commission that came out last year that I
was proud to be part of, and I promise I will never do one again because it's way
too much work. But,
we do have to think about workforce. We have to think about supply.
I think, many of you may be at Professor Cathy Cutler's talk on
Saturday talking about isotopes.
We have to make sure that when we have a patient in the scanner or the treatment
room, that isotope arrives that day, and it arrives in a
form that is usable and we can make the drug, because often we'd make it and
deliver it the same day. So we have a lot of things we have to do.
We have a very graying workforce, as you can tell by my hair,
that we have to make sure we get the right people in it.
But the opportunities are huge, but we also have to be very
realistic on making sure that we can't make promises we can't keep.
So in summary, I think that the opportunities are there.
Never been a better time to be in the field.
We do have some challenges, but when we deploy these drugs in a very thoughtful and
careful way, I really do think that we can make a profound impact.
And I think you've already seen from PSMA,
Lutathera, Julie's work, and others, that this is happening now.
This is the group that do all the work, but I really want to skip to this group.
This is the group that make all the drugs that I've been talking about, headed up
by Serge.
Couldn't do this without all the clinical collaborators and so much of this DLL3
work,
even though this new endocrine prostate has been supported by the Prostate Cancer
Foundation, I really need to give them a big shout-out because the support that
they provided for this, as well as the department Stand Up To Cancer for other work
that's going on in the laboratory. Finally, thank you very much for your attention.
Bang on zero, and I think it's Marcus's turn.
Great.
Thanks so much, Jason. I hope you can hear me okay. Yeah, it's a great pleasure.
Thank you to the organizers for inviting me to really speak on this panel alongside
Julie and Jason, and to share some of the work we're doing at Novartis to really
push the boundaries of radioligand therapy and expand beyond PSMA and
SSTO2.
Here are my disclosures.
I was told I need disclaimers, but I definitely don't want you to read all of
those.
And with this slide, I just wanted to get started, but I don't really want to
rehash the whole history of radiotherapy.
But when I came into the field about six years ago, I was always hearing
that RRTs or radioligand therapy is a new modality.
But the reality is actually very different.
It builds on more than 100 years of experience with radiotherapy.
Most certainly, of course, around external beam
radiation. But what has changed over the 100 years is
precision. We are now able to pack small amounts of radiotherapy into a
targeting vector that is then finding the targets on cancer cells,
delivering deadly radiation to those cancers.
The first use actually of radioligand therapies was already described in
1994. So there's about
25 years of experience in that space.
But I think what really reignited, and I'm very sorry the cursor, I think, doesn't
seem to work, but what's really reignited this field, was the approval in my mind
around
Dr. Tate, as well as Lutathera, as well as later on Pluvicto for the treatment
of metastatic castration-resistant prostate cancer.
So it's really kind of a renaissance of the field, not necessarily a new modality
overall. And I think what we are now seeing is really an explosion
of this particular field. I think we are still, of course, riding the first wave of
innovation around SSTO2 and PSMA.
We're still working heavily with lutetium-177.
But when you look at the number of clinical trials that just have actually started
last year, we have seen a whopping 94 new trials in
2025, really looking at various different radioligand
therapies in development, and I'll get to some of those details later on.
I think what we will see in the next few years is this next wave of innovation,
what we are here today to talk about.
New targets, new disease areas beyond prostate cancer, as well as GEP-NET,
new isotopes beyond lutetium. There's a lot of talk around
actinium-225, terbium-161, or lead, just to name a
few.And eventually, I think the goal is where this field is heading,
hopefully, right? That it's going to be a core in the oncologist toolbox to
really treat all different kinds of cancers in the future.
Now, as everyone knows, we have two approved radioligand therapies to date.
One is lutetium PSMA-617 for the treatment of
PSMA-positive metastatic castration-resistant prostate cancer, and the other one
is lutetium dotatate for the treatment of SSTR2-positive
gastroentero pancreatic neuroendocrine tumors. So I also made it like Jason.
But the key question actually is how can we replicate this success?
How can we actually make novel radioligand therapies?
And there's actually four different areas of innovation that is currently happening
in this space. And in the middle, you see the principle setup of a radioligand that
consists on the one end of a target
on cancer cells, but then the ligand itself that is composed of a targeting vector
that, as Jason was saying, can be an antibody, can be a small format biologic, can
be a peptide, can be a low molecular weight, a linker, and a
chelator that links or homes the radioisotope that is
then eventually delivered to cancer cells.
And in all these different dimensions, innovation is happening.
For today's talk, I'm going to focus a little bit on targets.
What are we thinking about? What could successful targets look like in the
future? How do we try to identify novel targets for
oncology? I will speak a little bit about isotopes, how we actually try to
diversify that, but bit from a different angle this time.
How can we actually use the properties of isotope to actually overcome target
heterogeneity? And I'll speak lastly a little bit about combinations.
What we do know about radioligands is that they extend the lives of
prostate cancer patients, of GEP-NET patients tremendously, but cures are very
rare. So I think we do definitely need combinations to maximize the
efficacy of radioligands.
Now, this is just not, again, to kind of go into all of these details, but this
slide just kind of shows you the explosion of that field that I was referring to
earlier. We are still very much anchored around PSMA and SSTR2, and
most late-stage trials are definitely around those two
targets. But there's a plethora of new targets that people are exploring
and that are actually now moving into clinical trials.
The question, however, is going to be very critical is which of those targets is
going to deliver the next radioligand therapy?
I think there are beautiful targets out there, but maybe some that are not that
great. But ultimately, there need to be certain criteria met that actually
would make it a very promising new
therapy.
Now, what did we actually observe in successful targets?
The kind of way that I think about that, let's first learn what
the successes look like. How did PSMA become this
successful radioligand therapy in prostate cancer?
And there's a few elements there that one can clearly, of course, highlight.
One is that it's very highly expressed in tumor cells, and it's extremely abundant
in most prostate cancer patients.
It has a very good high tumor-to-healthy tissue differential, which
of course, increases the TI that you can actually treat patients.
The physiological expression of PSMA is largely confined to non-life critical
tissues. Of course, it's expressed in salivary gland, it's in kidneys, but
those side effects are all mostly manageable in the clinic.
It's a highly tractable target. It's druggable, it's accessible, obviously,
and it actually shows efficient internalization, which we can debate later
if actually internalization is necessary for radioligands.
I'll get back to that later in the talk with the principle of crossfire, why I do
believe it's not essential to truly need internalization, but in this particular
case, we of course seen that.
However, PSMA, with all the success, also has limitations.
And I think this is where we need to improve upon new targets in the future.
So it's very clear from us and from our studies and others that clinical
response to lutetium PSMA-617 is clearly associated
with higher tumor absorbed dose, which tracks with target expression.
So on the left are data from literature, actually, but we have replicated this data
also in our VISION trial data, that when you have high homogeneous PSMA
expression, you see high uptake of the tracer, which is probably not
very surprising, and those patients would actually do best on therapy.
And that actually kind of very nicely tracks with respect to uptake that
we are seeing in those tumors. It correlates, as I said, with absorbed dose.
This is the panel in the middle. So the responders have clear higher tumor absorbed
dose than the non-responders. And you can actually also see that when you look at
IHC from resected tumors, that the
uptake definitely correlates with target expression.
Now, the problem with PSMA obviously is, and this is what you kind of already see
in this slide, that it's a highly heterogeneous target.
Now, while there is a lot of expression in most of patients, there is a lot of
intra and inter-patient heterogeneity.
And you can beautifully see that with PET imaging on the left there.
So you have patient with high homogeneous that respond best, high heterogeneous
expression, as well as patients that have low expression that respond most poorly.
So now the question is not only how do we actually push the low expressers
to kind of receive more absorbed dose, this is not necessarily topic of the talk,
but when you think about next generation targets, how do we actually maximize
the probability of success? And one element of that is, of course, to
maximize for target homogeneity.
We really want to think targets that are expressed on all the tumor cells.
And you can actually assess that, as this is Novartis data of two targets that I'm
not allowed to name yet. But this is HD visium spatial
transcriptomics of individual patients with non-small cell lung cancer
of the squamous type. And you can basically see that target X, I think you can
appreciate that there's a lot of homogeneity in all of these patients, while
target Y shows much more heterogeneity.
So you obviously want to favor targets that have high
homogeneous target expression across all of these
tumors.So with new targets, we definitely aim to
improving upon this intra-patient expression heterogeneity
by upfront selecting targets with much more homogeneous expression.
And one of those targets you already heard from Jason, actually, that we also like
quite well, is DLL3, which is a highly expressed target in neuroendocrine
tumors. And if you look at the left there from different tumors of neuroendocrine
origin, if you zoom in, you actually will see that all of the tumor cells
express DLL3 despite the fact that it's a low abundance target.
And that would qualify as what we would think of as a highly attractive target with
respect to homogeneity. Actually, we went on, or our
colleagues at Mariana Oncology went on to develop ETN-029,
which is an actinium-based macrocyclic peptide ligand targeting
DLL3. And I just show one set of data on the right there, which is
a SHP77 tumor xenograft model, where we observe that
dose-dependently DLL3, this DLL3 peptide can regress these
particular tumors. ETN-029 is now in clinical trials,
and much like the work that Jason and others are doing, we are very much
looking forward to see some of the first results of those trials.
Now switching gears a little bit,
and talking about radioisotopes, but really actually from a very different angle
than just, say, we're delivering higher energy with alpha particles.
I start to kind of ask the question: Can we overcome target heterogeneity by
using long-ranged isotopes? And
what we have to mention there, the most commonly used isotopes in clinical
practice, whether it is as beta or alpha particles, differ
not only by their energy, but also their path lengths.
Beta
emitters, they emit electrons that can travel roughly one to
two millimeter into tissue and damage tissue around.
Alpha particles, on the contrast, only travel for a few microns, so really
just only actually targeting a few cell layers in
tumors. So can you actually use those properties, this radioisotope
biology, to overcome target heterogeneity?
And what I mean by that is, again, exemplified by PSMA.
In a way, when you look at the tumors and then actually not only look at PET, what
I just showed you before, but when you take those tumors and actually analyze them
by PSMA IHC, you will basically see that you have different
patterns, right? You see that some of these tumors are well infiltrated, and tumor
cells are in close vicinity to PSMA-positive cells all
around. But there is also quite some gaps sometimes.
And what I just told you about radioisotope properties, that some of these isotopes
may not travel far enough to actually kill all the tumor cells.
So while you might get a nice therapeutic effect, you might also
very, very quickly get regrowth.
Now, choosing between those could definitely help with overcoming target
heterogeneity. So how do we test that?
And instead of just now doing and performing mixing models where you try to
recapitulate that in vivo, all these different states, which is
extremely hard, and probably quite impossible, you
can turn to a tumor microenvironment target.
And there's many reasons why we love Fab and why we actually want to target Fab.
And in itself, it's a very attractive nuclear medicine target, but it's actually a
model system to actually model target heterogeneity and
this so-called crossfire effect.
Because we have to assume that if this works, what I just told you,
crossfire needs to be actually real.
It has to actually fire from DNA target positive
cells into target negative cells, induce DNA damage
beyond the binding event, and then thereby lead to cell killing.
Now, that's all sort of depicted on the left.
Fab is expressed on cancer fibroblasts, and you have a model system all of a sudden
in vivo where you can actually probe that, the firing into cancer cells.
Fab is, of course, overexpressed on many different tumor types, but most
notably in PDAC and in some of the subtypes of breast cancer, where
the infiltration of fibroblasts is extremely homogeneous.
So you can actually test all of these different hypotheses.
Last year, actually, at AACR, we disclosed for the first time the
discovery of NNS-309 or FXX-489, a Fab-targeting
RT that we actually developed at Novartis.
It's a high-affinity
Fab binder with picomolar affinity and has solved for many of the
shortcomings of first-generation Fab molecules, most notably the tumor retention
time that some of those first-generation molecules suffered from.
So we see a really great tumor retention with these molecules driven by the very
high affinity of this molecule. It's highly selective.
It does not bind to any of the very closely related targets in this space.
I still always have to mention that the DOTA chelator itself contributes
significantly to the binding. It's quite fascinating how that chemistry actually
works. And it demonstrates high proteic stability.
But you can use this now, and it's currently in Phase I clinical trials.
But you can use this now to actually probe this biology that I actually just told
you about. And we first did that in
PDAC patient-derived xenograft models, where actually mouse
fibroblasts infiltrate into the tumor.
You can see the staining there on the top right.
So it's kind of reminiscent of what we see in patients.
And you can see that FXX elicits tumor control on the
left. But does it actually elicit crossfire?
So can we actually use lutetium to crossfire into different areas of
this tumor to really kill it off? And we did some PD
experiments where we basically took a bit of a different model, which had one very
peculiarity. It's a syngeneic model where Fab is actually
surrounding the tumor. So it's kind of this rim model that a lot of people in this
field are using. You can see there on the right, the IF of Fab, this very
distinct stain of Fab around the tumor.
So that's a beautiful model that you can actually see whether it actually
crossfires in. On the left, we did IHC, treated these animals with
FXX-489, and you can, I think, appreciate compared to vehicle control
that
tumor cells actually have gamma H2AX staining.
So really DNA damage inducing. You can also appreciate that we are, of course, not
only killing tumor cells in this model, but we are also seeing a
tremendous induction of DNA damage in fibroblasts.
Again, we can discuss later what that actually means.
And in the right there, just for better visualization, we have then treated this
also. We did IF for gamma H2AX, and you can clearly see that this
actuallyYou know, infiltrates, right?
And so ultimately, the way that I like to think about that a little bit or what
I started to think about, can we actually use tumor microenvironment targets to
circumvent some of the shortcomings of targets in cancer cells that we are seeing?
If you actually look beyond prostate cancer, there are not that many great targets
out there, right? I think there's a lot of great highly expressed targets that we
all know about, but there's also a lot of normal tissue expression.
Can you find tumor microenvironment targets that actually would solve for that?
It's not only FAB, there may be many more, and use this cross-fire effect and
lutetium to actually kill cancer cells.
Now, for the last part of my talk, for the last five minutes, I want to switch
gears one more time and speak about combination therapies.
I told you before that
radioligand therapy works really well in patients, but cures are very
rare.
And there's various concepts that we are following.
You heard also some thoughts from Jason on the opportunities.
And you can think about multiple different mechanisms how to combine radioligand
therapies for cancer therapy. One of which is immunotherapy, of course,
orthogonal disease-specific targeted approaches, standard of care therapies,
or key tumor dependencies, depending on what tumor type you're targeting.
Definitely also very interested in combining or alternating RT agents,
alpha/beta, right? The tandem therapy that you already heard about.
Maybe target upregulating approaches.
Can we actually
increase, for instance, PSMA expression in PSMA-low tumors, so different
pharmacological intervention, and then basically treat those tumors with, for
example, PSMA 617 or radiosensitizers like chemo,
as well as DDR inhibitors. And we took a very pragmatic approach at that.
Depending on the targets that we look at, we look at what are the standard of care
therapies that you see on this particular slide, and can we actually
synergize radioligand therapy with all these different therapies?
And we started again with NNS309. Obviously, treating
your pancreatic cancers again, and at the time, standard of care.
I know we have heard new data, of course, coming through from targeted therapies,
so we're definitely going to do these experiments in the future.
But at the time, a standard of care therapy combination with nab-paclitaxel and
cytarabine. And I think what's really exciting about those data is that there's
true synergy. That the single agent activity in at least mouse models was rather
limited. But if you actually combined FXX 49 or
NNS-309 with this doublet chemotherapy, can truly regress
those tumors. We have went on to show this in multiple different models,
and are now, of course, also very interested to explore these
combinations clinically.
One thing that you just heard from Jason, in addition to cytotoxicity, it's quite
well known actually that radioligand therapy or radiotherapy
itself induces immunogenic effects.
This is not our data, but it's grounded in this idea, as Jason
outlined, that radioligands would lead to immunogenic cell death,
potentially activation of the immune system, and that could sensitize to different
immunotherapies, including checkpoint inhibitors, but also maybe other agents.
And there is some first clinical data there on the right.
This is not the latest data set that is released from the PRINCE
study, which is a combination of PSMA 617 with
pembrolizumab in prostate cancer.
There was just an update of the final data that was published a couple of weeks
ago. But you saw quite some promising responses in this patient
population, but larger studies, of course, and more studies with different
combination partners are needed to truly
look at the full potential of these therapies.
Now, the last thing that we do is, again, going back to more mechanistic
rationale combinations. And what we did in collaboration with Artios Pharma,
we looked very specifically on the DNA damage response pathway inductions that
are elicited upon radioligand therapy.
And here's just one example where we actually
treat cells with lutetium DOTATATE,
and then just look over time what happens with respect to DNA damage.
And sure enough, as I already told you in other settings, we induce double-strand
breaks as measured by gamma H2AX or 53BP1.
It's actually very important to note that this kinetic is very different than
what you see with external beam radiation.
External beam radiation sort of works as a bomb.
You
elicit all the energy on the tumor, you induce
great damage, but it wears off within hours, actually.
And the repair mechanisms start to kick in quite quickly.
So radioligand therapy is a very different kinetic, which is very important when
you consider combinations, but also therapy in general.
And that you see there quantified on the right.
So we asked the question together with Artios Pharma, can we identify
radiosensitizers that actually would then qualify as combination
partners for our radioligands? And we actually
performed CRISPR-Cas9, as well as short hairpin
screens, which we knocked out the DDRome.
We didn't do this genome wide, but we did the DDRome, and we treated those cells
with lutetium, and then asked the question, which of the ones drop out?
And sure enough, in three different cell lines, one of the top hits was actually
DNA-PK.
Now you probably could have said, "This is very expected.
Why did you even do this experiment?" We found more than
this, of course. But DNA-PK is a very actionable partner
that you can
really go after in the clinic very quickly because there are molecules
developed by others that have targeted
DNA-PK for therapy. And so you can basically then just do that experiment and
really confirm the findings of these screens.
So either you do it genetically by knocking out
DNA-PK on the left there, as well as with a tool compound
that inhibits DNA-PK, and you can see that you can sensitize cells to the
combination of lutetium DOTATATE as well as DNA-PK inhibition.
You can, of course, take this further into in vivo studies, and we did that in a
prostate model that is genetically engineered to overexpress PSMA,
and we also see some synergy with respect to DNA-PK.
We do believe that it's a very broadly applicable mechanism that should not be
confined to just one tumor type. It's very likely, of course, that
those mechanisms will be elicited across different tumors, and we are also
now looking in clinical trials whether this combination can drive
benefit.So I think I'm almost out of time, or I'm out of time, but I only have one
more slide. Just to kind of summarize, how can we continue to develop
transformative RRTs? And I think
it's going to be multifactorial. We do need to understand the disease, really start
at the bottom. What are actually the target populations that we want to go after?
What are the best targets in those different indications?
And, which of these targets satisfy some of the criteria that I
tried to outline during my talk today, most notably the tumor to normal
differential, the homogeneity of expression?
We need to understand the isotope. Do we need crossfire?
Could we go with other therapies that would deliver greater energy?
And we need to understand the vector.
We like peptides, as we have seen, and we are very much innovating around
that space. But there, of course, are many other things that can be used.
All of that underlies radiobiology.
I think it's an area of investigation that is extremely
underexplored still. I think, but we are now really picking up and
learning. And all of that also needs to, of course, be informed by clinical
learnings. As we are seeing all these clinical trials take off, we're hopefully
going to learn and really be able to
integrate some of those learnings from clinics with respect to safety profiles, but
also using imaging and dosimetry that you heard a little bit about today into this
learning and into this pyramid. And then hopefully really develop next
generation RRTs for the future. And with that, there's way too many
people at Novartis as well as our collaborators to put on one slide, so I decided
to just
put categories. But we're really grateful to the entire Novartis RRT and drug
discovery teams,
our friends at Mariana, Artios and PeptiDream, as well as the Beyond leadership
team, and thank you very much for your attention.
Okay, now we've saved time for questions.
And please, yes. Good. Use the microphones.
Hi, this is Timo from PeptiLab. It's a very nice talk.
So I have only one question for each of the speakers.
The first one is for Julie. It's about a brain metastasis.
So it's very beautiful work. You showed uptake over the brain.
Because is that like a case by case scenario because the patient got a
brain metastasis, their blood brain barriers damage is different.
So what's the efficacy? Have you measures, like a quantifies, what's
the efficacy for those patients that have the images
after cross the blood brain barrier?
So yes, it's probably compromised blood brain barrier. You're correct.
That's probably why we're seeing these mets.
We were concerned, would it go everywhere?
Well you saw, no, it just goes to the site of metastasis.
So when you're saying efficacy, we're not treating, we have not treated the
brain met. That patient I showed you went on to external beam
radiation to treat that brain met.
From an uptake point, it's more about the detection, the SUV values in the brain.
I think we've seen between three and five.
So to the point where we're looking at prostate, will something respond?
I don't think we can say, "No, it won't, because it's not got an SUV of 10,"
because our molecule's not the same as the therapeutic.
So our SUV is just a, is it present? Is it present enough for us to
then move forward with treatment?
So we haven't treated brain met patients
with our lutetium yet.
Okay. And so what's the overall response rate for
brain metastasis patients? Have you measured that?
No. No, we haven't.
Okay. Only two or three patients. Okay.
All right, the second
question is for Jason. It's about a DL3 expression rate.
We know it express pretty low copies, right?
So for PSMA, there was a small molecule activator to increase the
PSMA expressions. So for DL3 in the future, is there going to be such
kind of the same similars, like small molecular activator or something like that
to increase the DL3 expression?
There is. God, that's loud. There is.
For example, we can increase the expression of HER2 or
stabilize it on the surface of a cell just by giving a simple statin, and we think
that might even affect how patients gain treatment.
So a lot of these antigens are amenable to some form of modulation.
There is some work now coming out of Charles Sawyers' lab,
where they are able to show or do some work, I believe, that will actually start
increasing the DL3 expression. Or what they're trying to
focus on is actually stopping the transdifferentiation from
the adenocarcinoma to the
neuroendocrine prostate cancer, and that's about all I understand and all I can
explain. So you have to wait for Charles to publish it.
But I don't know if he's here, if he can answer it, but no.
But yeah, we're definitely looking at that.
And we're looking at smaller fragments and all other kinds of things to hit it
better.
Okay, great. Sorry. Last question from me.
And could you make some perspective on the combination landscape?
Because definitely we're going to use the IO combining with
radiotherapy. So how about compete with a combination therapy
between ADC and IO? So or
like a TCL engagers. So how to compete with
those combination therapies?
Yeah. I'm not sure that you actually need to compete.
You actually think about whether you can actually combine as well, right?
With T-cell engagers as well as with ADCs.
I think there's mechanistic rationale for that too.
We have started with things like chemotherapy, but you could think about ADCs that
have a chemo payload, right? Which would result in the
same output, right? And so I don't think it's competition.
I think it's actually sort of trying to get into the spaces.
We are very early.
There's only the first trials that have been kicked off, so we definitely need to
learn. But I don't think it's mutually exclusive.
Right. Okay. Thank you.
Okay. This side.
Hi. Thank you for the talk. I'm Scott Goldsmith with City of Hope Myeloma Division.
To kind of springboard off of his last question regarding the combination
with T-cell engagers, any insight yet on when
we should be using the radioligands as priming,
from a dosing and scheduling standpoint with some of these immunotherapies?
Or is it still yet to be determined?
Yeah, I think there's only preclinical data on that thus
far. That would really guide our choices of what we could do.
I think people start to now combine that truly with checkpoint blockade, and I
think we will learn. I think there was some intriguing data also from Dr.
Morris in the educational session that you'd likely need actually low dose,
and I think that's also what Jason kind of said, to sort of activate
the immune system instead of killing actually everything.
I think there's a way that if you go in too high, and that's true for
chemotherapy as well, you're actually going to kill off everything first.
So there's definitely this idea of maybe low dose immunotherapy,
then checkpoint blockade. T-cell engagers would be very similar, I would say.
I think, again, it's depending on where you want to do it.
I think it's probably more suitable for immune cold tumors where you try to get
T-cells in, instead of immune hot cancers where T-cells are
pre-present, where maybe other combinations might be more logical
to try. But I think it's, again, very early days, and there's no
clear understanding in my mind where we should be going.
Thank you.
Winston Tang. A more fundamental question which will impact drug
development. What is the ideal vector?
You have peptides which are small, about 10 kilodaltons, so the
half-life is
less than an hour, as opposed to an antibody, which is
150 kilodaltons, with a half-life 21 days.
But at the same time, when you look at the ADCs, they
penetrate less than 5% into a tumor.
So how do you balance the two?
Well, as I was saying earlier, when I started in this field, I was a small
molecule guy, then I became a peptide guy, then I became an antibody guy.
Now I'm "I'll do whatever works" guy.
Because everything has its pluses and minuses.
If you want to image a patient to see if target is present, an antibody is not
ideal
because you may be waiting five, six days to get the image you want.
But if that's the only thing you have at hand, like when we started the DL3
campaign, that's-- We have an exquisitely good-
I was thinking more in terms of a therapeutic.
Oh, the same.
If you have a peptide-
Same argument. Yeah.
-then you have to have continuous infusion.
No.
No. Just single shot.
But that's gone within an hour.
No, we can modify it.
It's gone from the circulation, right? But not from the tumor.
Unless you manipulate it by putting the amino
acids or doing cyclic
peptides,
it's eliminated within an hour.
From the system, but not necessarily the tumor.
Yeah, you can
optimize it. The albumin binders, for example, that we talked about, the
cyclization, the unnaturals, and then you're correct in the sense it's
like then it's not just a which is best, it's how you're monitoring this.
Like Jason will say, he's doing his antibody, he's doing a longer lived.
For us, with the peptides, lutetium is probably too long for us.
Because we're in a sweet spot between probably 24 and 48 hours for our
peptide. But to Jason's point, once they're in the tumor,
they're not coming-- Well, in our case, they're not coming out.
So they're washing out of the kidneys, things like that.
That's the advantage of the peptide that's going to penetrate, right?
Because they're only 10 kilodaltons.
Whereas the antibodies,
the ADC field, you know only less than 5% penetrate.
Yeah, but again, okay. Yes, but if you're talking about a therapeutic
with the antibody, as long as you get enough radiation on that antibody,
ADCs, you've got to get a certain amount of the DC to do the treatment.
With an antibody, you just have to get enough of the tumor in order for the
radiation to irradiate them.
If you have an alpha emitter, it's not going to penetrate.
You're only binding to the surface of the tumor.
Well, that's why I think perhaps a mix-- Well, yes, but I think the other
thing with the alpha emitter is the fact it's going to irradiate everything around
it,
and so it doesn't matter if it's attached to the positive tumor cell or the
negative tumor cell. It could damage both those cells equally.
But let's say you have a one centimeter tumor.
All you're going to penetrate is maybe the top 10 millimeters.
Which may be enough.
Oh, but I mean, that's when you have other tumors.
But not every tumor's created the same and everything's round.
So you have to think about other approaches.
Yeah.
Exciting talk. I just one simple question.
So for antibody mediated to this therapeutic,
so we know the liver, there have a lot of the FC fragment
receptor. How to avoiding this side effect?
Yeah, that's a really good question.
So as I showed earlier, when we do the antibodies, we can go up to about 50
mgs,
total body, not ADC. And the reason we do that, we start off at three mgs,
and then we often co-inject deliberately non-labeled
antibody to help clear out the FC sinks.
We also do things like decoslate the antibodies to make sure that they don't have
FC mediated uptake. The DL3, it turns out that when you--
Some of that DL3, we only need three mgs and we do have a very clear liver, and we
can see the liver metastasis. Other ones like the CA99,
we had to go up to, I think, 30 mgs, three mgs radioactive and
27 non-radioactive in order to fill up those sinks first.
You could do it with a non-specific IGG, the same thing.
We generally use the
cold antibody. Because again, we're doing it total up to
50 mgs total body, not per kilogram.
Hopefully in the January session, we can also have one about co-administered
agents, because I think it needs a whole session on that.
But my name is Deb Nguyen, I'm with Photinia Biosciences.
My question is about the tiny box you had around accessibility.
So can we speak to which indications are now coming at
the next forefront, now that we're beyond prostate and
NETs?
Yeah, I think
there's not only one. There's multiple indications where RTs are being
tried. I think the way you can think about that is like you want to choose
indications that are highly radiosensitive to start with.
I think lung cancers, for instance, are obviously top of list. Breast cancers.
A few others that I think we see development
happening. I think the key question will, however, be which one of those will
respond best to radioligands. I think this is exactly what we just don't know yet.
And I think that's why it's incredibly exciting that we have all these different
trials, all these different molecules that are being tested broadly at this point.
But again, it's really around radiosensitivity that you want to guide that with,
in my mind, right? And that's how I think people also think about that, and that's
what we are seeing.
Hi.
I guess this is for Alex and Marcus.
The use of DNA repair inhibitors, you
mentioned DNAPK.
When they implemented that with the external beam radiotherapy, of course, it
didn't work very well. But do you think that a combination
with radioligands is going to have a better therapeutic index?
And if you do, why?
That's a great question.
How are you going to do it?
Yeah, that's a great question. I think it was, as you said, it was always limited
by toxicities, right? If you treat with DNAPKs
and other inhibitors of that class, you definitely have side effects.
I think the key is going to be scheduling again
similar to IO therapies, actually. Right?
And so what we tried to do, and we did a lot of preclinical work on that, and we
have presented that prior, really trying to understand how long do you need to
actually be on target for DNAPK? So how often do you have to treat, and how do
you maximize that window? So we figured out that you don't need continuous
treatment. You can actually vary that.
And with non-continuous treatment, you also diminish or reduce the side
effects. So that's how we approach it.
It's certainly not easy, but that's certainly something that we think can work.
Nice, thanks.
Joanna Kubo-Wiesinska, NIH, representing a very
underrepresented cancer at this conference, thyroid cancer.
Treating patients with dosimetry-based radioactive iodine, and my question
relates to dosimetry. We utilize I-124 PET/CTs to
predict both the maximum tolerated activity as well as what could be
accumulated in the metastatic lesions.
Yet, the most commonly used, Lutathera, utilizes this
200 millicurie empiric fixed approach.
What are your thoughts on dosimetry?
Are you considering using, I don't know, five to 10 millicuries of
lutetium dotatate in order to see what's the biodistribution?
Is there any translation of any PET ligands
to lutetium feasible? So this will be my first
question, and we have another one. I will let you answer this one.
Yeah. So dosimetry is key in about everything.
We need to do dosimetry thoughtfully, carefully for every patient to
make sure they're not either underdosed or overdosed, and I think that's important.
When it comes to thyroid, of course, that's the original theranostic.
Yeah.
It really is. It was image with the iodine and then treat and ablate with the
iodine.
And astatine, I saw the trial that's coming out of
Japan now, where they're using astatine as a surrogate for iodine, and I
think they're seeing some really profound results using the same transporter
process. But I think everything we should have more careful dosimetry, particularly
in pediatric populations, of course.
Making sure that we only treat with the amount of activity that's
needed to get a response and not, as I said, over-treat or
under-treat.
But what ligand would you use for dosimetry?
Oh, for this-
Would you small, tiny diagnostic dose, like five microcurie?
Oh, yeah, just a small-- You have surrogates, so we can use zirconium
for lutetium on an antibody. You can do gallium for lutetium like you would with
NETspot or Lutathera.
But the gallium has a short half-life, so yeah.
Half-lives are different.
Yeah.
There are some true theranostic pairs like lead-203
and lead-212.
Uh-huh.
The terbium sisters or daughters they're called.
Then you've got an alpha emitter and no gamma emitter, an alpha emitter,
and
one even emits positrons. I can't remember which. We'll have to ask Cathy Cutler.
She'll know.
Yeah?
It has both
They have spec MPET, so they have the whole shebang.
So there are other isotopes which are perfectly matched isotopologues, to
coin Brian Seglis. But that's not always the case.
And another follow-up.
To your point, it should not be 200 millicuries for every patient.
Yeah.
It should be personalized, to your point.
Yes. And another question related to the previous
question. So,
how to make sure that we are not killing off lymphocytes
if we are considering combination with immunotherapy.
So are there any data, I don't know, maybe from external beam
radiation? What is the dose threshold to guide us?
You know, low dose is a very vague term.
What is the
killing dose for the lymphocytes?
Yeah.
Could it be extrapolated from some-
Yeah, I don't think that we have that dose yet, right? I think that's not known.
But the fact is that all hematopoietic cells are extremely sensitive, right?
You
think about the just normal bone marrow sort of thresholds.
We talk about two Grays typically, right?
Where you normally see very strong cytopenias actually when you
surpass that. So, what that low-dose in tumor though looks like and
how tumor-infiltrating lymphocytes, et cetera, would react is something
that is certainly not defined yet.
But I think it's important that we will study that clinically eventually,
right? I think it's no different than to chemotherapy, actually, when you think
about chemo IO combinations, right?
Chemo at MTD, when it's given to patients, will kill off everything.
Right.
And so that also would not work. The other way of thinking about that, well, maybe
I don't care, and I just wait until they reinfiltrate, right?
I think that's also well documented, and that is also true for radiotherapy.
So if you treat, and you may treat high dose, you may accept that you kill
everything off. You wait a week or something, and then it's coming back, right?
Because you elicit this immunogenicity, and then you go in with PD-1s or
other therapies and then basically try to maximize the effect.
I think it's kind of like two ways of thinking about that.
Question will be, what's the most effective one?
And I think then to add to that is what is going to be the isotope of choice,
because we also know that lutetium and actinium differ, right, with respect to
immune cell activation.
Right.
At least pre-clinically. Again, to be seen clinically.
Thank you very much. Fascinating talks. Thank you.
Of course.
So my question towards Marcus. I see in one of the slides, you're
talking about FAB.In some of the tumors, it's a surrounding one, so the
FAP localized at the edge of the tumor, and the core tumor, there is no FAP.
Yeah.
So what about we are treating FAP with even longer beta
radionuclide, longer distance of the beta radionuclide, for example-
Yttrium
... yttrium 90, so that the core tumor can also be radiated?
Yeah, no. It's a great question. I think we use this one tool that we
showed. I think it's a very special case, by the way.
It's a syngeneic model that just happens to have this ring-shaped
phenotype of FAP fibroblasts. If you look actually at patient samples,
we did this quite thoroughly and broadly, you don't necessarily
see just that, right? You always see infiltration.
The question is how much infiltration do you see? Is it rather sparse, right?
Or is it actually very, very interspersed, like for example, in PDAC or
in some
breast cancers.
But yttrium is a very fair consideration, traveling of course,
much, much greater distance. I think there's probably other issues with yttrium,
right, that you might want to consider.
And that's why I think it never gotten to a mainstay clinical use at this
point, right? That's why probably lutetium outcompeted yttrium because
overall it just has more favorable properties or that makes it work for these
therapies. But yeah, no, I think it's a perfectly valid question.
All right. Thank you very much.
Sure.
Actually, I think he-- Okay.
I've got a quick question for Julie.
Actually, so I think in the past and when we do the study for
the interim, sorry, integrins, that when we actually
seen that a lot of problem coming from the internalization because the
peptide preferred binding to the integrin, but it fastly washed
out over time. Is the same case for your peptide because I didn't see
the structure over there. So, is that worry you about
getting very fast clearance from the tumor?
And also when in the patient, see the lutetium
therapies and looks like most of the study has been doing the imaging for
one day off after the treatment. Do you happen to seen any
problem on the dosimetry-wise that the patient getting lower dosimetries over
your treatment because-
So,
I think your first question is, is our molecules internalized?
No.
Rapidly internalized,
and stays inside.
So it's in, trapped.
We're seeing that over days from the SPECT.
That one I just showed was a one day.
We SPECT seven days later as well. What we're seeing is
renal clearance, GI clearance, but the tumor is just
staying toasty. Some of the lesions from a dosimetry,
the high dose now, the 200 millicuries, some of these lesions are
getting 15 to 20 gray per lesion. We're also
not just looking at kidneys, we're looking at the individual tumors.
I think that patient I showed you with the CA 19-9 that was dropping,
there was a couple of those lesions got 30, 40 gray.
So we're getting the dose there. And again,
it's a single dose-
Yeah
... so we've got to do better.
Thank you so much. Great work.
Thank you very much. Very nice presentations.
In one of the educational sessions, I think it was mentioned that heterogeneous
target expression within the tumor is actually favorable or associated with
an official outcome. Yet today it was mentioned that you want, for an
ideal target, it should be highly expressed and homogeneous.
So how does that come together? Is it just indication by indication?
Sometimes you want heterogeneous, sometimes it's homogeneous?
Yeah.
Great question. I think if I remember correctly in the educational session, it was
related to the immune cell activation, right?
I think it was not necessarily related to what I was speaking about.
So ultimately, it's very intriguing to think about what Dr.
Morris has actually said about this, right?
We haven't recreated that data, let's say, yet.
But I do still believe that if you just look at clinical data of PSMA
617, right? That high homogeneous expression
tracks with response, right? And I think it's all coming down to how much
energy do you actually take to tumors.
It's of course not that simple, right?
It's not going to mean that you're immediately going to induce regressions.
If you have mutations in certain pathways, you might actually be much less
sensitive. But ultimately, again, if you look over populations, right?
That tracks quite well. So personally, I think, again, with respect to the
immune IO combinations,
again, we just have to explore that.
But if I were to choose a target, I definitely want to kind of maximize
for homogeneity to start with.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Hello. Great talks. Thanks very much.
I had a question about the antibody-based radiopharmaceuticals, specifically about
the circulating half-life time of them.
If they're on the order of two, three lutetium half-lives, are you worried
about heme talks? Are there issues with that?
Or are you relying on the tumor to kind of pull antibody out of the circulating
pool?
Yes.
It acts as the same.
Both. So yeah, absolutely. When you think about the
radio antibody circulating around, yes, you're going to worry about the time, the
radiation it's doing to normal tissues on its circulation.
There have been some trials that actually suggest that hasn't been as big an issue
as before, but then also there are other ways that you can circumvent that, because
antibodies are really, really, really good at getting their targets, and a lot of
it there is that background of that circulation issue.
So you can do things like pre-targeting.
There's pre-targeting trials now where you decouple those two things.
You give the antibody with some entity, click chemistry entity on,
let it circulate for a week, and you come in with a small molecule that attaches to
that antibody that's accumulated in the tumor but cleared out of the
background, and you can just come with a small molecule and you get it there within
hours. So there's also ways to decouple these two things,
because of that concern. Doesn't mean it's
not an issue that's being followed.
It also gets back to the fact that's why we need really well-trained people to do
this kind of work. They have to understand-
For radiotherapy, the half-life is pretty much determined by the isotope,
because the antibody itself is going to be there.
IgG is 21, 28 days.
Well, yeah, but if you put a-
But theoretically, the effect will not be there unless it's going to
fixcomplement or-
But if you're putting an actinium-225 with the 10-day half-life onto an
antibody, then that's a lot of irradiation.
If you put lead-212, which has a 10-hour half-life on an antibody-
But then you can't ship it.
No, but then you can also make your own generator, like some people have done.
Thank you.
I think one last question over here.
Last question.
Actually, I was going to ask you, Jason, about can
immunoglobulin ever be used as a carrier for a
radiopharmaceutical, but you just discussed it.
And then I was going to follow that question with, if pre-targeting would
work, and you also mentioned that.
I know
pre-targeting has been looked at, especially from, memory of Sloan
Kettering for over 10 years, and I
feel like maybe you guys close to put that
into a patient, but I haven't seen the data yet.
The trial's open. There are other trials, other places with the PRIT,
pre-targeting other centers. There is also one going on in Europe right now, which
is using that pre-targeting approach.
But we have used antibodies because, it's nice when you're giving a septin
and you label the septin directly, you've got the same compound.
Same with daratumumab.
Sure.
With DLL3, there wasn't anything smaller.
But then you've got very clever people like Anna Wu making Wu bodies.
Cis bodies, di bodies, Wu bodies, whatever which are smaller fragments of
these that you do get
of quicker uptake and penetrance.
So,
as I said, everything has advantage and a disadvantage, but sometimes that's
what you have at hand to use.
Just one quick technical question on Novartis.
So DLL3, you didn't use an antibody.
It was must be some kind of peptide.
Yeah. I mentioned it's a macrocyclic peptide binder. Yes, indeed.
10 years ago, there wasn't anything else but the antibody. So, yeah.
All right. Well, thank our speakers, and thank you for all your questions.
And to remind you that there's a lot of questions and a lot of
biology that we need to look at, and that's the special conference in January,
January 7th to 10th, where we're really going to look at the RLTs, how they
interact with other treatments, how we're going to combine them, what does it mean,
but from the fundamental biology. So I encourage you to put that on your calendars.
Thank you, everyone.
You're welcome.
Hi.